TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Actions on Google has a
new directory, more device
availability, and more control
of your home with Smart Home
control.
Details and links are on the
post linked in the description
below.
PageSpeed Insights
provides information
about how well a page adheres
to a set of best practices.
And now, it uses data from the
Chrome User Experience Report
to make better
recommendations for you,
and the optimization score has
been tuned to be more aligned
with the real world data.
There are three new
tools to help further
improve your workflows and
manage Apps Script projects--
the Apps Script dashboard, Apps
Script API, and Apps Script
command line interface.
Screenshots and more
are on the post.
The Google Brain
Team works to advance
the state of the art in
artificial intelligence
with research and
systems engineering
as one part of the
overall Google AI effort.
Check out these two
posts for some highlights
of their work in 2017, including
some of the basic research
work, updates on
open source software,
data sets, new hardware for
machine learning, health care,
robotics, and more.
The container structure
test framework
provides a convenient
and powerful way
to verify the contents and
structure of your containers.
We've been using this
framework at Google
to test all of our teams'
released containers
for over a year now, and we're
excited to finally share it
with you.
You can get started with
the details on the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this
week's episode of the Dev Show.
If you'd like to catch
some of our prior episodes,
they're right over here.